improving the medical response to a mass
shooting that's been the focus of top
trauma surgeons who just released a list
of recommendations now the study's
co-author and assistant dean for
research and professor of surgery at
corian school of medicine here in town
dr debra cools joins us now you led the
medical response to one october and what
compelled you do you want to do this
follow-up response
so following one october i think we
really did an after-action analysis of
what went well what could do better and
there's always room for improvement and
the ability to share
our experience to help other hospitals
other health care professionals be
really ready in case this happens in
their neighborhood or their hospital
and that that makes good sense i know
that um our state one of six involved in
this conference and um invite of
clinicians to take part and what were
some of the key takeaways
so there were a total of 19
recommendations
i think they fall into several
categories one is train and train and
train and train even healthcare
professionals that don't normally take
care of injured patients
also triage or sort patients
particularly from a mass casualty from
shooting
there's a higher likelihood of needing
blood and needing the operating room so
for instance when patients reach a
hospital to set
a triage area outside of the hospital
and to very quickly sort patients about
who needs
blood who needs life-saving operation
get those people into the hospital
sooner than other people who are less
injured
other takeaways
would be provide additional mental
health for the health care workers
because it's traumatic also for the
health care workers
if there's ability
to have a nearby military installation a
military civilian partnership
is very helpful and to encourage those
and in our case here in las vegas our
relationship with dallas air force base
was extremely helpful
so those are five out of the 19
recommendations
i know this was a response to when
victims wind up in the hospital but you
also talk a very about a very important
training prior to that part the public
training of stopping the bleed
absolutely
because
mass shootings any other sort of mass
casualty can happen without notice in
any location
so it's really important for the public
to understand what they can do
and in our own shooting there were many
many valiant acts to try to save lives
stop the bleed training actually was
introduced by the american college of
surgeons
after the sandy hook
shooting
and it teaches basic principles of
hemorrhage control how to apply a
tourniquet adequately if you don't have
one what else you can use and how to
apply pressure to a bleeding wound
these maneuvers can save lives yeah and
we've had plenty of those trainings
across our valley and you can always go
online to find the next one nearest you
if you would like to become trained in
that way as well dr kuhls thank you so
much for your time we greatly appreciate
you're very welcome